el destino del transbordador Columbia y
de sus siete pasajeros quedó sellado
nada más despegar un trozo de escombro
dañó el escudo térmico dos semanas más
tarde el primero de febrero de 2003 el
transportador se desintegró al regresar
a la tierra Más allá de las emociones la
conclusión es obvia dos accidentes
mortales y un total de 14 astronautas
muertos el transbordador es demasiado
peligroso y demasiado caro
[Música]
en 2010 el transbordador espacial tras
casi 30 años de funcionamiento será
retirado
para hacer frente a los problemas de
seguridad la NASA está volviendo a la
cápsula espacial y dejando de utilizar
los portadores polivalentes
hizo posible la construcción de la
estación espacial internacional y eso
era lo que se le pedía Así que cumple su
función pero los estadounidenses se
dieron cuenta de que tenían que volver a
una solución que no pusiera en peligro
la vida de los astronautas
la otra Revolución es ideológica para
reducir los costes de lanzamiento y
garantizar el servicio a la estación
espacial internacional la NASA Apuesta
por el sector privado spacex es el
ganador el lanzamiento de spacex de esta
noche marca el inicio de las misiones
comerciales de reabastecimiento por
parte de empresas estadounidenses desde
el país la NASA lanzó un programa de
transporte de tripulaciones el comercio
al club program y decidió su contratar
Este programa a la industria puso a
competir a los distintos actores entre
ellos spacex pero también Boeing en la
actualidad hay dos proveedores
estadounidenses que se reparten el
servicio a la estación espacial para los
astronautas y spacex ha tomado una gran
ventaja dos cambios relacionados con el
trágico accidente del Columbia están más
de actualidad que nunca la NASA Apuesta
por la cápsula de orión y spacex para su
regreso a la luna previsto para 2025